good
evening welcome members officers members
of the public to this meeting of the
development committee on the 8th of
January
2024 there are no planned fire drills so
if the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire
exit please use the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance of
the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission by
Council
staff please switch off mobile phones or
turn them to silent and please note that
the meeting will be live
streamed please ensure your microphone
is switched on when speaking and you
speak clearly into the
microphone
members of the public and press while
you are of course entitled to film or
take photographs during this meeting can
I please emphasize to you that this
should be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public
seating can I please therefore ask you
to raise your hand clearly in the air if
you wish to take photographs or film
this
evening no I see no hands thank
you
item one apologies for absence we have
apologies for absence from councelor
Brewer and councelor
laurman item two substitute members we
have councelor cross who is subbing for
Mrs Brewer
welcome non-members attending I don't
see any non-members no thank you minutes
of the meeting held on the 7th of
December
2023 uh do I have any matters of fact on
that to
question
okay thank
you Declarations of interest do members
have any Declarations of interest on any
item on the agenda tonight
please chairman I don't know if it's
relevant but I'm sixs County councilor
obviously as well as RC councelor okay
thank
you
counc can you use it you do M please
rord Parish Council okay thank
you and Council award Ry Town Council I
have a non-real interest in that the
item uh which is uh item six uh I am in
the same trade as the uh the applicant
and I know of him and so that is I
believe all of the Declarations of
interest uh now before we go chairman
can I just say R Town Council as well
councelor Stanley R Town Council as well
thank you um can I just say before we uh
go into any of the reports um I
understand that because there was a bit
of an IT issue the appendices that uh
came out this morning um that that's the
reason being why they're a bit late can
I uh just um be sure that you've all had
a chance want to read those
appendices
sorry say
again I haven't if anything come out
this morning I've been in meetings all
day okay um I'm minded under that those
circumstances uh to give us uh five or
10 minutes of what it
is I'm sorry I'm correction they came
out yesterday I have read those ones
thank you but I they come out yest if
anything come out this morning I
certainly haven't read them I I do I do
apologize thank you okay so we've all
had a chance of read them yeah okay
thank you so with that then we will go
on to the item number
six which is uh
reference uh
23742 443 Brook Road ra and ask KT
Rogers to present is it the report y
thank you hopefully you can hear me so
this application relates to 43 Brook
Road a site occupied by an established
joinery
business um the the plan on screen is
the submitted location plan and it said
red but it's a bit faint so I'll just go
around it with the light pen so the the
front site Frontage onto Brook Road is
is here to the South um and it's a
similar width um of the rear of that
site which adjoins the prop Residential
Properties on Woodlands Avenue to the
North The Proposal seeks a single story
rear extension in place of an existing
detached out building that's in that
position shown with the light pen there
CLA if you can go to the thank you so
the existing floor plan to the top of
the screen I don't know if you can just
zoom into that class slightly thank
you shows that the majority of the floor
space of the existing building so um
this is all existing um but this is the
sort of main building is occupied by two
Workshop spaces and the detached out
building to the rear which is this area
here um is annotated and in use for the
storage the elevation plan if you could
just scroll down please CLA sorry to
that the bottom of that that's fine um
the elevation plan says the existing
detached out building to the rear having
a jaw pitched a shallow pitch to the
roof here if you can go to the proposed
please and just zoom into the floor
plan thank you so the prop the proposed
extension would be in this location here
to the rear and it would replace that
existing detached out building that i'
just shown previously and again this
plan is annotated um showing the
proposed use of this floor space as for
storage the extension would have a width
um the same as the width of the existing
building to which it would attach and if
you can just scroll down um to the
elevation thanks CLA the detach the
building proposed would have a pitched
roof with the Ridge orientated in a
different direction and slightly higher
um but still steep down from the the
roof of the existing building that it
would attached to the only opening
proposed is this set of doors which is
in the elevation that faces um East into
the site as it were there are no windows
or openings proposed in the rear
elevation which um faces the rear Garden
boundary of the residential property on
Woodlands Avenue if you can go to the
area limit please CLA yeah that's fine
so this aerial image and if you can see
the site is is this one oops sorry here
the detached out building that's going
to be would be replaced is in the
position
here so this area image shows the
context of the application site which is
part of an established industrial site
but immediately adjoins this residential
area to the north and this residential
area to the East part of
RA a number of the other um industrial
uses Within estate you can see have
buildings that are quite close to the
residential um boundaries of other
Residential Properties
nearby this application seeks planning
permission for an extension to replace
the detached out building but it does
not seek to change the use of the
site the site has operated as a joinery
business for many years and this is a B2
use which is and the lawful use of the
site um we consider that the use is
appropriate um so it's the same use and
it's appropriate in the industrial
location um and the land for the
industrial estate is allocated as such
to support that kind of economic
business interest in the
district whilst the applicant has
indicated on the floors floor plan that
the um out bu that the extension would
be used for storage um there would
actually be nothing requiring that to
only be used as storage unless there was
a planning condition imposed so you will
actually note on the addendum that there
is actually an additional condition um
recommended which seeks to um limit the
use of the if you can go back to the
floor plan please CLA so the use of the
extension um for that stated use for
storage
only um this would prevent any sort of
noisy um noisy sort of Workshop use or
the extension of that Workshop into that
space and it would also um apply to any
other B2 type user that was going to
occupy the site in the future because
this applicant seeks it only for storage
but that's not necessarily what an or
rupar might want in the
future the impact of the proposed
development in terms of the scale of the
built development um on the residential
ameni so if you could go down to that um
elevation plan again so if you look here
if we could maybe zoom into that little
section there CLA so this shows the
relationship of the proposed extension
to the rear Garden boundary of that site
that are joins and some of the members I
know you've been to the site visit so
this is the um demarcating boundary
treatment and then this is the rear
Garden of that residential property
adjoining so what's been taken into
account is the extension or the um
bringing of that building closer it
replaces an existing building but this
is proposed slightly bigger but it's
considered that in terms of the height
the width the depth and the
relationships to that boundary it would
not um give rise to any harm in terms of
unreasonable overshadowing um or it
being overbearing because there are no
wind Windows proposed in the rear
elevation that would face that boundary
there's no Prospect of direct
overlooking causing harm to privacy so
in terms of the scale design and form of
the extension it is considered
acceptable um the extension would not be
readily visible to the public realm
because the Brook Road um public part of
that site is much further to the South
given that the extension will replace an
existing outbuilding in the same use um
and wouldn't significantly increase the
footprint we don't consider that there
be any additional need for any further
on-site parking provision um and the
recommendation is one of approval
subject to the conditions as um set out
in the report but as then additional
ones on the
agendum thank you
Katie members uh Ward Members First any
Ward members would like to uh comment
First Council
[Music]
W I wondered is there anybody speaking
on
behalf is there anybody speaking
with do apologize
again um we do have a uh public speaker
on this item uh Miss Glen uh please
accept my apologies uh come to the mic
and you will have five minutes to speak
uh from when you start speaking thank
you
good evening chair
members I'm a residence uh located
immediately behind that property I've
attended the side visit and still object
to the planning Point
[Music]
would it help um I I realize that this
is a very emotional thing for you would
it help if you've got everything written
down there someone reads it out for
you
minute
if if I may
intercede I do have a copy of this if uh
M then would like me to read it on her
behalf I would be more than happy to do
that if if not no it's I'm being advised
that if anyone should be reading out it
should be
myself it's up to you Miss Glen take
your time when no one's forcing you I've
stopped the clock
having attended the site visit I still
object to the planning Point 1331 relate
to the pitch and extension height which
is now a lot taller than the existing
which we do not see from our property
the planning officer never visited our
property and it's completely failed to
note that our garden in is on a downward
gradient and our house sits one and a
half meters above that level we see more
than the whole roof structure currently
at ground level let alone what we see
upstairs the extension is therefore very
imposing to us and doesn't reflect the
neighbors whose flat roof extension
actually only starts from where the wall
meets the
pitch and then reduces to fence he this
current proposal does detriment our
sense of space because it now takes away
the only remaining visual buffer that we
have from the main building that causes
us a lot of grief the unit offers no
boundary W or green screening to buffer
his existence or its operations
Point 21 and 23 unfortunately there
isn't a positive relationship with the
local immunity five houses raised
complaints are unhappy due to the join
hours of operation noise and smells
although I'm told it's not related to
this we are of course talking about an
extension which is supplying the
materials the very materials that cause
all of the grief to us living here all
of this could have been avoided if the
if condition two was not breached
instead the applicant had formerly
applied permission to operate there and
that the local Authority had neglected
in their duty while failing to enforce
said conditions I have documentation
from 19 the 1930s up to the up to
1970 which detail that when the houses
were built which was in 1955 first
residents moved in the
1956 it also details the planning set by
this local Authority in relation to how
that industrial state would be built the
distance from the current houses to the
start of those of that industrial state
it also mentions fences and boundaries
all of these things that were considered
then why are they not being considered
now and we still live there we also work
there we moved with the times people
work from home as well as live and we
have to endure the constant barrage of
noises smells and dust being woken up as
early as 6:45 daily Monday to Friday the
Summers nine months of the year you open
your your windows and there's a constant
barrage of offensive high pitch noises
and
smells condition too was really
important to ensure that the right kind
of business operates here to create that
harmonious environment and consider
consider the local imunity we are now
enduring the breach the effects of that
breach other areas that border this
industrial Stout have a whole Woodland
we have nothing and my remaining visual
buffer is now being removed by this
building of which the whole pitch I will
see so Point 25 referring to the local
Authority and enforcement is kind of
insulting and makes mockery of the
system because there's been a fail
failing by the local Authority and
continues to be so complaints of noise
to a year and a half to be initiated and
when they actually bothered to record
the noise a year later they set up
broken recording equipment in my
propy
the building is not fit for purpose of
location the walls are not
insulated just can't do it
anymore the walls are not insulated the
single pitch glass where is bringing
that building in line with updating
thinking of a carbon footprint or
anything would serve to
reduce and make our whole life a lot
better no one's saying to shut down this
business that's not what I'm aiming for
here bring the whole building up to
scratch there's neighboring buildings I
see in pictures from the mid-60s they've
had their whole buildings wrapped with
insulation I've had my house and window
I've had my whole house wrapped I've had
my whole Windows double glaze and I
still I still hear this constantly day
in day out tormenting pictures the
smells have a minute left it goes on and
on and
on as I mentioned in the S there's no
boundary wall no repair retaining Brocks
in complete state of disrepair do don't
understand why businesses NE next door
had to erect a two meter wall as part of
their planning when they extended why
are we not being afforded the same thing
here to Shield us from what goes on
there to prevent if there's a fire on
that skip which is butted up against my
fence where's the protection from a fire
there's nothing there there's no
boundary at all no boundary well they
knocked it down and they never
reinstated it it's in a complete
mess there's no mention either on the
planning about increased waste and
storage of that waste as a result in
increasing their capacity their smelly
waste and swust Productions not suit to
be stored buted up against our fence
which renders the use of that section of
our garden original planning conditions
had strict details around storage of
waste being inside that building and
because that was breached we now have
nothing and there's no end in sight
because there's no no conditions on
there and no one's enforcing anything so
I think that a boundary War needs to be
a condition of this extension it should
be used for storage only with powers of
enforcement attached to that any change
of business change of use or change of
owner should notify the Lo local
Authority for new conditions to be
instated and why not a seven-year plan
that when that owner reaches the age of
retirement if he wants to pursue his
business further that building should be
upgraded in line with other
environmental upgrades to make us all
carbon go our way towards our net carbon
for the future wrap the building bring
it up to scratch like other buildings
have had to do that would make a massive
difference to the quality of Our Lives
all living there behind that unit thank
you thank
you thank you Miss Glenn and uh I app
appreciate you bringing that you can go
back to your seat now if you if you'd
like and then the committee will discuss
the
issues I understand you want to play a
recording yes please okay um you are
well over your time but I will allow it
okay thank
you
this is from my bedroom inside my
bedroom in the morning at
6:45 screeching noise that we hear day
in day out that's we open my
[Music]
window this is the constant Screech goes
on and off in line with the compressor
that you heard on the site Vis it then
starting up and going
[Music]
down is my back door to my bench outside
my back
[Music]
door just sitting at my bench trying to
have some keys in a bit fresh air in the
day been spraying it
[Music]
smells all right thank you very much for
bringing that um and uh thank you m
Glenn and if you'd like to return to
seat thank you
there are no visiting members so Ward
members I believe the only Ward member
who's here is Council award if you'd
like to bring your points now please
thank you very much chairman
I I have actually been obviously to the
site I've I've been in Miss Glenn's
property I have heard those noises even
with the full double glazing it goes on
it's like like a tap dripping you know
psychological torture it literally is it
does not stop I know there's an industry
behind there and I know they got to work
I know they got a job to do but there
there is noise which needs to be abated
obviously I'm very disappointed that our
own enforcement failed to enforce over
many years and this goes over many years
where there should have been enforcement
on that site they've admitted in the um
in the actual report that it's become
lawful because they failed to do
anything you know that's down to us our
local Authority has not done any
neighbor any good service in regards to
this industrial estate originally there
was a buffer the industrial estate was
definitely born
subsequent to the housing and there was
a buffer in the original plan that
should have been in there and that was
it because there's the stream and such
like this has not been maintained in any
way there just been Mass encroachment
all the way all the way through so you
know
unfortunately I mean as far as I'm
concerned unless we have conditions on
here for the whole of the building I
know we've only looking at the extension
at this moment but I feel personally I
cannot support this application in any
way shape or form unless we are actually
able to do something to make a noise
abatement around that
building that's very very important as
far as the neighbors are concerned now I
don't know how we script this I don't
know how we do this but I will be asking
for advice on what kind of conditions we
can put in there to minimize the noise
is it a fact that we need to do
something around the Machinery is there
something the decibel levels you know we
have um Community halls and things like
that I believe we've got one coming up
later that would have music there and
they have the decibel meters up there
which will turn everything off literally
this is something that needs to be taken
seriously and in and unfortunately our
environmental our own our en
environmental
Department had poor equipment it broke
down it didn't work and this was after
and she said it's 18 months nearly she
had to wait for it to go in there when
it was put in our home to measure it to
do it officially it was corrupted it
broke down you know this is a real
failing on the local Authority and I'm
sad I'm a member of it you know but I
have to call this out it's a fad a bad
failing um but I I would like to know
exactly what we can do and how we can go
about putting in conditions especially
the last one you know as far as the uh
the extension is concerned yes only
storage absolutely not use for anything
else and I'm glad that's in the addendum
but I think we should have some form of
um buffering to protect from the noise
whether it's inside the building outside
we need to I need the officers to come
up with something
that will help now we're a bit late to
the party but it doesn't have to be the
end we can actually show we can do
something to solve this problem once and
for all and hopefully it can be enforced
thank
you thank you councelor ward anyone else
councelor Shaw councelor
Shaw thank you chairman I wasn't able to
go to the site visit but Katie can you
bring up
um the original where you it just shows
you I want to see um where the buildings
are uh building is to the houses please
so about first or second slide you put
up so it's the yeah it's the Google Map
sort of one you
put
yeah is between
the industrial units and the houses is
there a fence sale or anything is there
actually a fence or a buffer or trees to
do anything to mitigate I wasn't there
so I'm just asking the
officers I can actually uh answer that
one for you because I was there on
Saturday uh there is a six foot fence U
which is normal panel with chairman
behind you oh no uh it's concrete
pillars yes that's it concrete pillars
and and uh six fence between there was a
wall there years ago um and
unfortunately the boundary issue is not
part of this this planning application
but yes there is offense there so there
that's what I want to make sure there
was like between that and that thank you
very oh right that's what I wanted to
say thank you
chairman hang on Council refd first
please I'm sorry thank you chairman um
like to support this but with a
condition of an acoustic fence which
would help because if we don't support
this it's going to stay exactly the same
for the people who live there so this is
a opportunity to make their life a
little bit more bearable so could we
I've put on there as a condition an
acoustic fence because I I feel they
worked very well in great wakering with
the trading estate there with back
Gardens of
people
councilor Ward I believe you were next
thank you chairman yeah the fence you
can see there is actually the it's Miss
Glenn's fence it's not that's her
boundary it's not the boundary that
should be there and the buffer zone you
see the very small buffer zone where the
grass is growing that's the buffer zone
I guess as best it can be there should
have been a wall the wall has been
knocked
down have we proof of that
yes sorry councelor
sanley thank you chairman um whilst I
hear the fundamentals that are going on
with this it is
the owner who has to M said and I quote
on
6.5 number 27
28 that and 26 the proposed extension
will cover the extractor fans and also
the noise from the generator
unfortunately we can't use that building
to cover the noise from the workshop it
is only that building that we are
looking at now if that happens to be
that enforcement hasn't done it over the
years
previous and that's 20 years let's say
then that's it's par part and parcel of
the development that has occurred on on
making the business what it is um as for
the skip yes that can be covered um but
that's nothing to do with the building
as such that is something for the
environmental health officer to decide
or the environment agency to decide how
to deal with that thank
you thank you
K you want to come back yeah please um
so I mean I I sympathize with the
concerns that the resident has expressed
tonight um but in determining this
application I think what we need to be
mindful of is that there is a lawful use
of the existing building taking place
unrestricted by planning condition in
terms of either hours of operation or
level of noise that can be generated so
that doesn't mean that noise generated
in that building is not for the council
to consider but it falls to be
considered through the Environmental
Protection and environmental health Team
and what we need to be mindful of I
think is that this proposal is for an
extension that doesn't propose a
material change of use and it's our
officer view that the conditions that
have been imposed are the maximum extent
that we can go to um to ensure that this
extension use which is proposed for
storage only would not generate any
further um noise concerns for the
resident it will not address any
concerns they have in relation to the
noise generated within within the
existing Workshop building it will it
does seek to enclose those existing
extract um so hopefully that would give
some benefit in terms of those being
enclosed in a kind of robust building
now but any conditions that we seek to
impose on this consent if it's for
approval must meet those tests necessary
and related to the development that is
proposed tonight which is for an
extension to store
Timber c c you want to come
back um can we put a condition on there
when we spoke to the owner on Saturday
said the walls were going to be
insulated which would obviously deaden
the sound but could we um impose a
condition that the roof is also
insulated to some extent and that would
save the noise from going through the
roof and going further as just as a
condition of the development because
it's not honorous and I think it would
also go some way to allevia in the
sound in terms of you your your is your
sort of train of thought that noise from
I still think that that's seeks to deal
with noise from the existing Workshop
use because what we're suggesting by
condition is that the use within this
extension will be limited to the storage
of building materials so I get that you
know insulating the roof of the
extension might buffer Some Noise
transfer potentially from the existing
Workshop building but I just think that
that probably wouldn't meet the tests
well but I feel that obviously with
insulation they put in sound insulation
in the walls um so that would help
deaden the noise but you've also got the
extract unit which is discharging into
that extension um and that is noise that
will travel up through the roof those
sorry so if you if you insulated the
roof as well or do you put some form of
insulation there that would just deaden
the sound a little bit and I think it's
a very small condition that I don't see
any reason why we can't add it it it
might seem a small condition and I'm not
trying to be difficult but the
conditions must meet the test and the
fact is those existing extract units are
open okay so they're not enclosed by
building at present so simply the
building actually as proposed enclosing
them should be of benefit I think what
we would see that condition would be
seeking to potentially you know deal
with the noise of those existing extract
units even further and I think that goes
probably Beyond what's reasonable and
fairly and reasonably related related to
an extension to store wood which an
outcome of which is that those extract
units are enclosed within that
building well let's agree to disagree on
that one then okay councelor cross thank
you chairman um like many others here I
have every sympathy with the residents
of joining this um uh industrial uh
estate but uh Katie's actually answered
um many of the points that I was going
to raise in that uh the plan doesn't
actually show the uh the extraction uh
ducting uh which will be covered by this
new extension so that in itself will M
mitigate the uh noise certainly from the
extraction duct um there's only going to
be storage in this extension so that in
itself won't generates um any noise um I
think if I lived in those properties i'
I'd have some tall conifers there to you
know to deaden the noise and I
understand there may have been those
sort of conifers in place at one stage
that's not really relevant but if it was
me living there i' I'd you know try and
establish something like that again but
um yeah I think case's really covered
all all the points I was going to raise
thank you chairman okay thank now um
I've got Council Ward I think you've
already had quite a bit of input so I'll
allow one more come back please
um can we go back to the actual uh
diagram please of the
plans can we go inside the building can
you tell me what is going to be
separating the timber storage and the
main
Workshop is there is it a dividing
wall there is no entrance from the
workshop in into that extension at all
is that
correct um so yeah that that that wall
there is the existing rear wall of that
building um and then the extension is
just sort of wrapping around that that
oneall okay so the timber storage will
only be accessed from outside of the
building okay that's all I wanted to
know whether there was a material change
in the building thank you Council what
counc left
thank you chairman um going be a little
bit argumentative Casey um the condition
youve put on there for the uh the
building to enclose the extractor fans
it seems like the owner has identified
that there is a noise problem so surely
if he's identified there is a noise
problem and there is a noise problem so
maybe we confirm up a little bit
stronger on that because he's admitted
there's a noise problem and also with
the being storage you can have vehicles
going going down there early in the
morning unloading and loading into that
for the storage so wood is going to be
smashing and bashing up about there so
don't want to stop them working but I
feel there should be better noise
reduction okay Katie yeah know I I do
sympathize with this res when you get
these uses next to one another like an
industrial estate right butting against
Residential it you know it definitely
gives rise to this potential for the to
be this you know difficulty and tension
between those uses interacting with one
another but the fact is that the whole
site is authorized for a B2 use as a
this Timber joinery business so the
outside spaces the the existing
outbuilding although it's smaller in
footprint it's already used for storage
you're already getting the the the wood
being taken down there at present so in
that respect I don't think that this
proposal introduces anything different
I I can sympathize with the um sort of
um idealized view that you could use
this application to seek to control the
use that's happening on the site further
to benefit the existing residents that
put onto the site but that's just not
what the planning we can do in the
determination of this
application okay thank you ka I'm going
to wrap this up now um I think there's
been enough um discussion it uh my
thoughts on it is that um I have every
sympathy with Miss Glenn um but we as
members of this committee have to be
considering this application on the
merits of the
application and I think Katie has made
that very clear um we do have members
here do have a lot of sympathy uh for
Miss Glenn when we had the site meeting
on Saturday we had a little bit of a a
time to have a chat afterwards and I
hope that some of the information and
the advice I gave her there uh is
helpful um there are other issues here
but they are not relevant to this
application and I think we need to be
careful that we don't actually overstep
the mark on here and actually bring
ourselves into a bit of a sticky
situation so I need a uh proposal uh
someone to propose uh the approval or
otherwise councelor
Stanley um I'll accept the proposal for
this to be
passed approved okay do I have a
second and councelor Shaw second okay uh
all those in favor
please councel well can I know exactly
what the conditions are now before I
vote they are they're on the report
[Music]
they're what about um adding on the CH
when the change of business change
tenant with regard to um the change of
the
storage so what the the conditions um as
I understand it you know a motion has
been tabled to follow the um
recommendation which would impose the
conditions as set out in the report so
that's the three conditions on page
6.7 and then the two additional
conditions on page four of the addendum
so condition the additional conditions
on for relates to no mechanical
extraction ventilation equipment no
additional windows or doors should be
inserted on any of the external W um
walls or the roof of the extension so
only the double doors that are shown
proposed um on the Eastern elevation and
then condition five that the floor space
of the extension shall be used solely
for the purpose of storage and no other
purpose okay
okay okay so let's take that to the vote
then we have a proposal in second those
in favor please raise your hand
okay thank you those against please
raise your
hand any
extensions
yeah okay that item is approved I trust
that um as a result of this that the
problems being highlighted that uh Ward
members will actually take this up and
help the uh the neighbor with the
ongoing issues thank you right moving on
now then to item seven uh this is uh
planning application
23829 plot 8 airport Business Park South
Ur or way rodford CLA Buckley will
present the report oh to you
CLE
so this application is a full planning
application for the sighting of a
commercial unit for B2 and B8 use along
with parking service yard and
Landscaping at plot 8 the airport
Business Park South End the airport
business park has had various
permissions granted for commercial
development since outline permission is
granted in 2015 including a Costa Coffee
which is located here a unit for use by
the company CA that's going to be
located here two units for ourco one
already constructed here one underway
here um the Launchpad building so that's
the structure that we can see there and
then a collection of buildings known as
the quad and that's those just
here so the business park itself is
located to the east of Cherry Orchard
Way SED between Aviation way and cherry
or Brick Works members will recall
recently that cherry or Brick Works
received reserved matters consent for a
retirement village and that's a site
that's located just to the north here
and as you can see this is our
application site outlined in red just
bottom here so the application site is
located the southern boundary with the
estate road to the north here um we also
have the quad buildings directly
opposite an access road through to
Aviation Aviation way um to the east
along with one of the io buildings and
to the West is a green Corridor um with
footpath link footpath length and to the
South or industrial units within
Aviation
way
so the building would be a
rectangular-shaped commercial unit with
predominantly open warehouse space
internally but also with a twostory
office to the Northwestern corner just
located
there the parking area will be located
to the west of the building here with
its own access off of the estate Road um
and the service yard will be to the
Eastern side of the building equally
with its own access off of the estate
Road there would also be a refuge store
and parking spaces within this area here
The Refuge store there and some more
additional parking there there would be
soft landscape into the northern and
southern
boundaries so this shows the proposed
appearance of the building with light
medium and green gray cladding colors
there will be glazed into the
Northwestern corner so as you can see
here um at both ground and FAL level
where the office would be located the
building would be 11.85 meters in height
let's have a quick look at the ground
floor the floor plan so this is the
ground floor plan of the building it
would measure 3,23 8 square meters in
floor area including the FL first floor
space which is located directly above
the ground floor office the main
building entrance will be located the
Western El oan here and then we've got
three um service um accesses here as
well so the key material planning
considerations are the principle of
development economic benefits access
transport and highways design layer and
appearance Landscaping flood risk and
surface water drainage sustainable
design and Bram ecology and biodiversity
and air quality so looking at the
principle of development the fundamental
objectives of the council's economic
policies in relation to the airport
business park has been to promote high
quality job creation in 2022 a
permission amended a condition on the
2015 outline consent and provided an
upper limit of 10,000 M squared of ba
use prior to this the outline limited
the amount of ba8 to 1,000 M squar the
Restriction was to ensure that ba8
storage uses do not become the
predominant use across the business park
as they do not carry the greatest
Prospect of creating and supporting high
quality employment
opportunities which was the intention of
the business park previous decisions
have followed the 2015 objectives and
sought to prevent a dominance of B8 uses
however since these decisions were
issued the council have published the
2023 Economic Development needs
assessment which represents new evidence
for the emerging local plan
this shows that the forecast need for B8
uses is now likely to be significantly
higher than determined in earlier
adopted evidence on this basis and in
light of the evidence on market
conditions it is considered that a
departure from policy to enable a B8 use
to operate is Justified here however
officers do seek to prevent Self Storage
by condition which would not be
considered to a lie with the aspirations
of the only creating quite limited
employment numbers looking at economic
benefits an economic benefits statement
has been submitted which explains the
proposal will provide 45 to 90 full-time
jobs once operational along with adding
financially to the local economy this
together with the economic development
needs assessment and market demand
further assists in justifying a
departure from policy here in officers
view looking at access transport and
highways so the proposal will provide 45
car parking spaces which includes three
disabled bays and 10 electric vehicle
charging points and also 22 bicycle
spaces the parking Bays meet the minimum
standard but this has been accepted on
other plots within the airport Business
Park site a draft travel plan has been
submitted along with a servicing and
deliveries plan County highways raise no
objection subject to conditions these
have been imposed within the
recommendation but the monitoring fee
for the travel plan would be subject to
unilateral undertaking that the agent
has agreed to
submit design layout and appearance so
the design approach using cladding of
varying gray coloring is consistent with
that which has been previously consented
across the business park and
incorporates the use of high quality and
contemporary materials that are durable
yet appropriate for the proposed use
with regards to layouts the design code
for the outline application Illustrated
two built forms either side of the site
and centrally placed parking flist plot
whilst it would have been more
beneficial for the unit to front the
biodiversity Corridor the current
proposals are broadly in line with the
design code fist plot and are considered
acceptable there are missed
opportunities to provide outdoor seating
and tables within the layout for staff
but a condition requiring this to
provided has been included with the
recommendation to address
this on Landscaping so the hard
Landscaping proposed uses a mixture of
concrete bin makum and permeable block
Paving soft Landscaping includes new
tree planting new grass areas ornamental
shrub planting hedge planting and Native
buffer mix a metal perimeter fence is
also proposed for
security a condition requiring
implementation of the Landscaping has
been attached to the recommendation
including the need for a greater Quantum
of trees and improvements to the soft
Landscaping
proposed on flood risk and surface water
drainage the drainage layout submitted
shows a proposal to provide geoc
cellular storage per Paving and filter
drains and to discharge at the desired
controlled rate County lead local flood
Authority do not object to the proposed
drainage scheme subject to conditions
which have been attached to the
recommendation on sustainable design and
briam so the briam preassessment
submitted confirms that the scheme would
achieve a rating of very good it is not
viable for the scheme to meet the
excellent rating and in consideration of
other developments on the airport site
this rating is considered
acceptable looking at ecology and
biodiversity so the ecological appraisal
submitted concludes that the overall
impact is considered to be neutral and
finally on air quality an air quality
assessment has been provided with the
application this recommends measures to
minimize construction phase dust
emissions but overall concludes that no
mitigation measures are required so the
recommendation is that Planning
Commission be approved subject to the
applicants entering to a unilateral
undertaking to provide for the
monitoring of a workplace travel plan
including relevant fee and subject to
the conditions within the officer's
recommendation and the Amendments and
additional conditions identified within
the addendum thank
you thank you CLA there is one speaker
on this report Mr dimt is speaking in
support of the application if you'd like
to come to the microphone you have five
minutes from when you start to speak and
I'll give you minutes warning when you
get to the end thank
you thank you chair my name is Nick
Diamond I'm a partner at night Frank and
I've been hbds planning advisor on the
airport Business Park since
2014 if I can start by thanking your
officers for the positive recommendation
uh and for their assistance uh
throughout the planning process um
despite covid the trustman budget and
the current economic slowdown hbd have
delivered in excess of 35 ,000 square
meters of employment floor space across
the business park capable of
accommodating in the region of a
thousand jobs B2 and B8 application
before you this evening responds to the
current demand and will allow our client
to continue to deliver the flexible high
quality employment space capable of
responding to Future demand I'd also
reiterate that the design of The
Proposal is in keeping of a similar
design palette as that already on the
site
this is a well-balanced employment
sector delivering increased productivity
diversity in roles and higher earnings
Recent research by the British property
Federation has highlighted the focus on
more technical roles in management
analytics it and Engineering alongside
above average earnings within the sector
as acknowledged by your officers and the
updated 2023 employment evidence
Logistics and warehousing along with the
flexible permission as proposed this
evening can support a range of Highly
skilled productive occupations without
impacting upon the role or function of
the business park once completed and
fully occupied it's estimated that the
proposed development could accommodate
between 45 and 90 direct full-time jobs
plus additional employment through
construction management and more widely
through the supply chain in conclusion
The Proposal before you will deliver
further complimentary offerings at the
airp airport Business Park deliver
significant economic and employment
opportunities to the district and help
to ensure its continued growth and
resilience and contribute to the
council's wider aspirations of
delivering new jobs and growth to the
district we therefore ask that you
follow your officer's recommendations
and approve this application thank
you thank you Mr D if you like to return
to your seat I don't believe we have any
Ward counselors here do we there's no no
uh no um non-members or visiting members
I should say here to speak so straight
over
to members C refy thank you chairman uh
can you tell me where the travel plan
where's the name is bus stop is a bus
that actually goes down
there no I believe it's something that's
in negotiation but is not currently
right I'd like to make a proposal on
this that the S6 County Council get a
£6,000 when a bus goes within 100 meters
of where it goes other than that because
they just ask this money have got no
intent don't never seem to have any
intention of putting any sort of viable
travel alternative other than cars or or
bikes and we've already built all the
infrastructure for the bikes and we and
person's building the P spaces for the
electric cars and the cars so I'd like
to see a little bit of incentive for se6
County Council to actually do some work
for this money for their travel plan
which they've insisted on having so you
can you just clarify exactly what you're
asking for please right the 106 which is
like
6,383 West East County Council have
asked for for travel plan which it can't
work because there's no bus route or
buses that go down there my question is
more is how are you asking for that to
be held back yeah back into a bus go
yeah okay is that possible
um esss County Council high is the ones
obviously provide us with the advice and
guidance on what appropriate mitigation
um is necessary for certain developments
in this case they have proposed um
Quantum of money to monitor specifically
the travel plan um it wouldn't be
appropriate for us to ask for them to
provide that money or for that money to
go towards a different area because it's
for for them to decide where that money
um is put to that they are requesting or
they are saying is necessary to mitigate
any harm can I just come in I'm won't be
able to uh do anything on this because
I'm S6 highways and I'm also on the
sustainable travel and I'm also running
the buses so I'm afraid I will sit on
this but I will not be able to vote or
make any comment understood and I think
that will reply to the next uh item as
well then yeah I'll just make sure that
I'm you're aware that I will not be able
to do this okay okay understood thank
you for that coun Stanley councelor
Stanley thank you chair um we have uh on
page seven uh
7.5 uh sustainable
drainage um and I refer to where it says
limiting discharge rates of two lers per
second um that's not the actual actual
flow rate of it should be less than 2
lers per second I believe um and in the
of storm which we are having storms
quite concurrently on on top of one
another and one in 100 years is not
quite what we are talking about it
doesn't work like that I only wish it
would but it doesn't um with the amount
of roof space over that I would like to
see if it's possible to do some sort of
um uh Plantation if you like where we
have S where we have a attenuation ponds
uh some sort of some sort of Plantation
instead of just the perimeter that we've
got of the building on this on this
screen at the moment I'd like to see
something put
in where it could be put in I don't know
but the uh S6 County council with their
flood alleviation program that they've
got and they've recently done some work
uh on this where um container of if you
like attenuation is is underneath the
plantation on top um I don't see as
though there there isn't is much there
that you can put that uh water too so so
your question is so my question is is
there room for any of the attenuation
ponds
or um attenuation tanks or whatever I
don't know what it what it is that goes
into the ground because it's it's a
um it's a site that's been filled in and
if water gets into that that will cause
a quite a bit of disruption to the
ground and I just have feelings that the
the attenuation tanks won't be big
enough CLE so just in response to your
um very first point about the discharge
rates um so that that this these
conditions we've imposed with regard to
sustainable drny should be have come
direct from ESS County Le local authori
so they specifically what they consider
appropriate for this site so that's come
from our Specialists on that with
regards to the discharge rates um the
actual attenuation pond so there
wouldn't be the capacity on the actual
plot that we're looking at itself to be
able to accommodate attenuation ponds
but what they have put forward is what
county lead local flood Authority
consider to be appropriate drainage
because they are proposing um
attenuation basins um underneath the or
geocellular storage um the other
phrasing for it um underneath the ground
which would hold water and then would
charge it very slowly um to the to the
necessary drainage points from that and
we've also got permeable Paving that
will be across parking spaces as well so
that collectively is considered to
represent appropriate um service order
drainage for the site yes uh chairman
just coming back it doesn't mean to say
that the flood Authority at ex County
Council know what they're doing because
we are having a meeting with them as I
speak next week or next fortnite um to
uh for them to evaluate what what we're
talking about it's just that it seems
that we have asked Builders uh on sites
to put in more than what is more than
what they think is adequate we've asked
them to put another 10% or even 20% in
some cases and I just have a feeling
that because the site is an infill with
materials underne that that once the
water gets into that that uh infill it
will cause a lot of problems a lot of
problems not only for the drivers
because the water can't go anywhere and
it's and you you need to you need to
make more of a attenuation ponds than
what you do than you think is necessary
that's that's where I finish thank you
yeah thank you I think one of the issues
that I have with although I understand
your point is that we don't have the
expertise on the committee here to be
able to challenge that um from the point
of view of actually having out the
experts
whatever you think of them um essic who
do hold the the final say on these
particular issues um I think it's it's a
question that could be asked but I don't
think it's something we could deal with
tonight I don't know what do you think
Le yeah I mean as well to note this
condition 12 does require um details of
the actual sustainable sustainable drain
to be submitted to and agreed so it's
still not um finally actually rub stamp
you say in terms of the actual drainage
Arrangements on the site having being
said having said that there is not the
capacity on this actual footprint to
provide attenuation basins like what we
might have on some obviously bigger
major development schemes where they can
obviously all be incorporated in we also
have the biodiversity corridors and
actually I don't know if there's any
attenuation ponds on those elements um
on the site or not already um I can't
confirm that for definite but I'm just
looking at the location plan and
obviously we've got sves here and I
don't know whether there I'd have to
sort of look up a lot of the history to
know for definite but the plot itself um
whilst we do still need to agree Serv
would range details um what we have seen
so far in terms of what's been submitted
um is considered countyal auth Authority
can I just come back chairman those
those ponds that we you've just uh
indicated they they are there for that
development of that and if the if the
water is released from this site and
goes into those ponds they will be
they'll be overflowed they'll they will
be redundant they're not holding
anything they're only holding enough for
for that site not another site on top
and that's the reason why I'm asking for
more detail in the attenuation and
whether or not where's that water going
to go in actual fact if it goes into
those ponds then they'll be overloaded
and therefore we will have problems with
that water and so I would ask
specifically more details on that and
how we can make it more rebant more uh
uh sustainable okay I think from what
I've heard it is something that actually
still has to be worked on so they are
things that maybe you can question
through the process with our planners um
to see on the on the process but I think
we do have to rely on our planners to be
able to actually come up with the right
answer for it but yeah Point made Point
made
understood Council
cable thank you can I when I was reading
through it this um office is a
speculative build uh does that mean we
don't know or this it is speculative
it's said in the plans does that mean we
don't know who the occupier is and what
it's going to be used for correct it's
um it's they're seeking permission for
B2 or B8 um but there is not an intended
occupier at the moment so we don't know
exactly what company would be or how
they would operate but it would be a B2
B8 flexible use so anybody who would
fall within the B2 or B8 could come in
and use that site thank
you Council Ward thank you chairman it's
just following on from Council
C Constable's uh query about speculative
nationalist I'm actually very pleased
that uh money is being invested to be
able to do this but I am disappointed
I've seen nothing in regards to Net Zero
on this building whatsoever I've not
seen any encouragement to put solar
totally through on the roof and the use
of gray
water at all I've not seen that I mean
this has come up with um uh count counc
Stanley um there there could have been
tanks put in there to use gray water
throughout the building and there should
also be net zero this is a great
opportunity by the developer to actually
make this a state-of-the-art building
where he's actually now using Net Zero
as one of his marketing tools I think
it's I think it's a great thing that
they're doing to put this into place to
encourage businesses in uh as you say
it's going to be up to uh uh V8 but I
would love to have seen solar on there
and I would say and I would recommend
you can't force a developer to do that
but I would suggest it would improve
their chances of marketing this building
if they do thank
you do you want to come back on that
talk
Le um so we do have um condition six I
know it's not solar panels but condition
six which is on page 7.3 is relation to
briam which requires that level of um
very good which again is all about sort
of sustainable design um and trying to
make sure um sustainability in the
design process of a build um there isn't
admittedly a condition with regards to
solar panels um but I think if members
were uh minded to approve the
application it's something that we could
potentially could add as a condition to
acquire detail to be submitted to Eng
grade with regards to um solar panels on
the site thank you would like that to be
considered sorry yeah yeah just just to
add council award that um in the
officer's report on page
7.22 it actually says that this proposed
building will meet a EPC rating of a and
to achieve that obviously then there
would need to be you know the materials
that are actually used in the building
itself would make it highly sustainable
with a rating of
a so just if I may come back on that
thank you much um obviously with car
charging and various other things that
will be increased I know they've got
charging points that they're actually
facilitating on site um it obviously
makes it worthwhile if you are actually
creating electricity from that
surface it it does make it viable far
more viable to actually do that so I'm
sure that the developer who is who is
listening now uh will probably wish to
put that as a suggestion going through
thank
you uh ion yeah sorry um just just
reviewing the fact that the the building
does seek to achieve an EPC rating of a
and the design of the building is
actually a flat roof building actually
installing solar panels as such um
actually wouldn't look too attractive so
I don't think we could encourage that I
think the fact that they're actually
stating here that it will be that higher
rate um of uh energy and sustainable
materials being used in its construction
I think that that's actually sufficient
thank you C cross yes thank you chair
yes I since that we don't know who the
Occupy is going to be um it may not be
relevant for them to u to have solar
panels if it's not a a power hungry uh
business then why should they pay for
something they're not going to take
advantage of is is my view I it's
something that they if they required uh
help with their energy costs then the
the occupier whoever that might be would
install the solar U panels and any other
energy saving um you know system heat
pumps Etc that that they wanted to but
we don't know who the Occupy is going to
be so it's just add in cost and and
making it less attractive and unslightly
as ion says in my view thank you Council
Stanley thank you chairman just uh just
to go back with the water situation can
that can we make a condition of using uh
rain water as as uh waste water in in
the in the building uh to collect that
because that would help a great deal
obviously to to everybody um to the
environment and also to the owner of the
building I would have thought thank you
sorry be with
me okay I'm I'm being advised uh page
7.5 of the report um when we go down to
the sustainable drainage about halfway
down there's a let me turn
out under sustainable drainage we get
down to uh the third bullet point from
the bottom detailed engineering drawings
of each component of the drainage scheme
um that has the possibility of being
considered under that that's the advice
I'm being given so it looks like it's
covered sorry there's
there be captur but the the case officer
have more deta okay um page 7.3 as well
sustainable design under brim um uh item
six uh it may well be covered on that as
well but I'm advised that the uh the
officers May be able to advise on
that yes I think um looking at those two
conditions I think it could potentially
be covered in either of those areas I
think sufficiently probably more so the
drainage one rather than the Bri I think
yeah okay
happy uh Council FD thank you chairman
I've got see no problem with this
development I might suggest that we have
a training course and reminds the
councils what is covered in the
briam because a lot of these questions
seem to be unnecessary if you actually
understand what's covered in them I
think that is uh a live Topic at the
moment so um yes we can deal with that
outside the meeting obviously but yes
good point um okay I think I'm minded to
move to a vote are we all talked out yep
okay right uh uh
so the recommendation is to approve the
application subject to conditions set
out in the report do I have a proposal
councelor Wilson seconder Council cable
thank you all those in
favor I believe that is unanimous with
the note of councelor Shaw who's
standing out the vote okay thank you so
move
on
item8 this is application
23715 sl4 plot 13 airport Business Park
South End Cher Al way Watford and CLA
back to you
again
so this application is a for planning
application for the sighting of a
commercial unit for B2 and B8 use along
with parking service yard and
Landscaping at plot 13 to the airport
Business Park South End so this proposal
is very similar to that just considered
at plot eight with the uses proposed
being the same the application site is
located in a central position as you can
see outlined in red here follow with my
cursor um with the estate road to the
north and curving around to the East and
parts of the green biodiversity Corridor
with footpath links just to the South
along
here to the West is an undeveloped
commercial plot so that's just located
here so the building will be rectangular
shaped commercial unit with
predominantly open warehouse space
internally but also with a ground ground
floor reception Lobby and then office
space above at first floor to the
Eastern elevation just here and along
this section here there are two parking
areas one will be located to the east of
the building access from the estate Road
that's this section here and another
would be access direct through the
service yard just located to the north
of the building here so the service yard
again would be just be to the West Side
here and then within the service yard
area we have Refuge Stores um just
located there there um and a substation
as well was also located to the northern
boundary just here there would be soft L
long landscape into all boundaries with
a greater Quantum to the northern
Edge so this shows the prop appearance
of the building with mid- gray dark gray
dark green and some feature white
clading colors there will be glazing to
the Eastern elevation where the office
and reception area be located so you can
see the quantum and glazing proposed
there um so and it was also wrap around
slightly around the northern and
southern elevations the building would
be 10.6 MERS in
height
so this shows the ground floor plan of
the proposed building it would measure
3,765 square meters in floor area
including the first floor space the main
building entrance would be located at
the Eastern elevation so just here there
with three service door accesses here
from the service yard
area and then
finally plan five so this shows the
first floor plan where there were two
large office spaces to the entire length
of the Eastern elevation so you can see
just slightly more office spacing than
what we saw at plot 8 just located
here so the key material planning
considerations are the principle of
development economic benefits market
demand design layout and appearance
Landscaping flood risk and service water
drainage access transport and highways
air quality
ecology sustainable design and briam
health impacts Heritage and archaeology
many of the material considerations that
were referred to within the previous
application presented to members for
plot a have the same conclusion for plot
13 so I don't intend to repeat this
within this presentation and members
will have had sight of the officer's
recommendation but I will explain to
members some of the relevant differences
so with regards to economic benefits so
an economic benefits statement has been
submitted which explains that the
proposal would provide 55 to 105
full-time jobs in comparison to the 45
to 90 at plot
8 so this is reflective sorry this is
reflective of the slightly slightly
larger unit size and it remains officers
view this along with the other matters
already raised assists in justifying a
ba8 permission here looking at access
transport and highways The Proposal
would provide 70 car parking spaces here
which includes four disabled bays and 14
electric vehicle charging points along
with 24 bicycle spaces again this is
reflective of the slightly larger unit
size and is in accordance with the
parking standards and then finally flood
risk and surface water drainage so the
drainage layout submitted CH a proposal
to provide surface water tenu and
storage County lead local flood
Authority initially raised a holding
objection but this was resolved and they
now no longer object to subject to
conditions which have been attached to
the
recommendation so the recommendation is
that Planning Commission be approved
subject to um just a number of things so
the applicants entering into a
unilateral undertaking to provide for
the monitoring of a workplace travel
plan including relevant fee again like
with plot 8 um also subject to the
conditions within the officer's
recommendation including the amend and
additional conditions identified within
the addendum but just two and again so
that's um the same as plot a but on top
of that as well we just two other things
um also subject to the removal of the
wording cited by condition 12 which is
on page 8.6 it just had a wrong
reference of condition on there so we're
just proposing to change that to cited
by condition 11 instead and which will
then correctly refer to the right
archaeological condition um which that
particular condition relates to and just
the additional one further condition um
we're looking to impose and that's
requiring floor elevation and material
details of the substation to be
submitted to an agreed prior to Works
commencing to construct the
substation thank
you thank you CLA uh we have one speaker
on this item again and uh that again is
Mr DeMont if you'd like to take your
seat and as before you'll have five
minutes I'll give you one morning one
minute warning at the end thank
you thank you chair uh I don't want to
take up any more of anyone's time um
than is necessary this evening just to
reiterate I think picking up some of the
points that you're you're the the
presentation made here in relation to
Suds it's the same situation that we had
on the previous um plot this has been
satisfied with um ess6 Candy count as
the lead flood Authority we do have to
submit uh mitigation um further details
going forward to that that will be
considered uh similarly this is a
speculative scheme but with as with both
schemes there's a number of ongoing
discussions with operators these
proposals are coming forward responding
to demand uh and also i' pick up the
same points regarding the sort of the
sustainability and how a lot of these
issues have been taken into account in
achieving the briam very good and the
EPC ratings so again I would just ask
that you uh follow your officer's
recommendations thank
you thank
you chairman it refers as again to me I
won be able to vote because I'm also
doing the SS as well as well as flooding
and sustainable transport thank you yeah
and you'll be excused from voting on
this one as well yeah okay thank you
Council
conable as this um application is very
similar to the former um I'd like to
propose that we go straight to a vote
and I would propose that this proposal
is passed okay yeah um can I just
suggest that we if there are any
questions that are not repeating what
we've heard before we have that hear
those questions first as long as it's
not repeated yeah absolutely yeah I will
stop any repeat Council
Stanley thank you chairman I won't
repeat the S situation but what I will
ask is that with so many cars parked on
the surrounding area is there going to
be and I don't know if we can enforce it
some some sort of uh filter uh situation
where the contaminants from the vehicles
that are now going to be
really pushing out some contaminants
whether a filter system can be
incorporated and can we make that as a
condition as we made it as a condition
to a football club not more than one
mile away from this point where I'm
standing or sitting rather so I just
wondered if we can make that condition
pleas I'm not really quite following
that but maybe CLA if you could come
back on that so I think again that does
Interlink in with the surface water
drainage which is all about making sure
that pollutants um from these hard
surfaces that are being collected in the
attenuation tanks aren't then obviously
dispersing straight into um the
attenuation ponds or U nearby streams or
anything like that and that would all be
dealt with as part of the overriding
drainage um conditions that we've got
imposed on the
recommendation and I say that chairman
is that SS recommend that swells filter
strips basins and ponds and wetlands
should be
incorporated 2.6 on on page
8.25 okay I would suggest then if it's
already in the report that that is is
going to be covered yeah okay there is
one question I do have um with the
electric car charging points am I right
in thinking they're all in the Eastern
Car Park not in the
northern
[Music]
yes it's these collection here I believe
that are in this Southern corner
here sorry yes so yeah the E area is is
there it seems as though we we we're
segregating out the one um sort of type
of vehicle which it looks to me like the
people who are going to be working in
the
factory effectively the manual workers
they're going to be in the car park that
has got no charging points I was just
wondering if there was any way that we
could actually uh request that some of
those charging points are put in the
other car park as well whether it it
just is dist better distribution that's
all I'm thinking around the car Parks we
have so condition eight does require
them to actually submit details around
the electric vehicle charging um anyway
so we do still need to agree where the
infrastructure stru is going to go um on
the site with regards to that um and
details of that and how it's going to be
laid down on site so that is still that
could still be covered by that condition
eight I think in terms of trying to
disperse them if I suppose obviously as
well if the infrastructure allows
because I suppose there's also a
consideration around maybe collect them
together as well for for other reasons
but there would be a cost cost issue on
that I understand but it does strike me
as being a little bit more uh measured
use of the car area let's say um yeah
thank you for that um councilor
Ward thank you very much it again is
just with with regard to solar flat
roofs um there is no reason why solar
cannot be put on flat roofs and we
should be aiming for Net Zero I'd hope
that would be some form of
recommendation that is within it and
that covers bream probably very good
doesn't but excellent does thank you I I
think to be fair we have covered that
issue in the previous uh um application
um any other questions couny I'd just
like to Second Council the Constable's
recommendation that we V move to the
vote okay we have a proposer and
seconder therefore we will go to the
vote uh all those in favor please raise
your
hand believe that is unanimous again
thank you very
much okay we move move on to the last
item now
this is the Rochford Recreation ground
Pavilion application
23342 for and uh Katie Rogers will
present thank
you thank
you so CLA could you just zoom into the
location plan that's in the sort of
bottom if you can just make that so fill
the screen
please
thanks that's fine thank you so this
application relates to the Pavilion
building which is shown by the light pen
there at Rochford Recreation ground and
it's located just off um stanbridge Road
and to the South and the red line site
you can see includes the existing
Pavilion building um and a small sort of
area of land around the building and
then um an elongated or a narrow stretch
of the red line site extend to the car
park that's just outside the site
boundary um to the east the remainder of
the replication ground you can maybe
just make out is edged blue and so
that's the wider site and you can see
that the are Residential Properties
bordering that wider site to the north
to the West um and to the
South the existing building is single
story um and the proposal is for a
single story extension to the front and
side of that
building go to the proposed plan please
CL
yeah thank you so this is the proposed
roof plan um and a dashed Orange Line
shows the extent of the um existing um
sort flat roof so in this area here
that's the extent of the existing
building on the site and you can see
that the proposed extension is this L
shape here and it would have um a depth
off the front wall of approximately four
meters um it would have a width off this
um Western elevation of approximately 15
M if you can take to the ne the proposed
there you go yeah so the plan in the
center of the screen is the proposed
floor plan if you can just zoom into
that a little bit
clar okay so you might just be able to
make out that dashed orange line again
and so this area here is the extent of
the existing building um and the layout
of the existing building would remain
largely unchanged um so these existing
changing rooms here remain unchanged the
only minor change is to the layout of of
the bar um and sort of some sort of
storage area in this location here the
proposed extension there then would add
um two changing rooms in this part of
the building here it would create um
additional sort of sitting area and
extend the bar which is in this position
here and it would add additional toilets
and then a separate storage area in this
western part of the building here you
can just scroll down on that plan please
yeah thank you so towards the bottom of
the screen are the proposed elevation
and in terms of design the proposed
extension would reflect the form of the
existing building um with a sort of very
shallow almost flat roof the external
walls would be rendered The Proposal
would include new and altered
fenestration to the front elevation so
that's this is the front elevation here
which faces into the recreation ground
um and altered fenestration and new
fenestration to the rear so this rear
elevation is closest to that Northern
boundary adjacent to which in fairly
close proximity is the rear Garden of
those neighboring residential dwellings
so most of the windows in this rear
elevation so that's that bottom one here
um in the existing part of the building
would remain the same so that's this
door here these sort of shallow Windows
here except this window here this one is
an existing window but it's proposed to
be replaced by a slightly deeper window
and that's proposed as a serving
hatch um in terms of the um New part the
extension that's proposed so this is um
a double door in the rear elevation and
a single window there's no fenestration
proposed on the um side
[Music]
elevation so the extension if you can
just go Um up to the floor plan again
CLA would increase the floor area of the
building quite substantially so you all
of this is existing would over double
the floor area of the building um an
unrestricted use may give rise to the
potential for increased impact on the
residential amenity of the occup
occupants of nearby Residential
Properties um by way of noise um
disturbance um you'll see on the
recommendation a condition is
recommended to restrict the use of the
extended building to between 9 and 11:
p.m. on any
day um the the same extent of Paving so
if you can see on that plan here this is
the proposed but there is the same
proportion of Paving to the front and to
the side and to the rear on the existing
building so what this does it seeks to
just create the same dep of of Paving
around the extension and just extend it
along the rear elevation up to this
point
here and then if you can go to the
proposed site plan please color yeah so
in addition to that Paving that's
proposed around the extended building
all along this line here um is prop is a
new foot path so at the moment this is
just grassp um but in inclement weather
this can you know get muddy whatever so
this is proposed to be a Ted surface
along that foot path there and you can
see on this plan um there are a number
of trees um close to this foot path that
be hard surfaced and a tree protection
plan has been submitted and an arult
impact assessment to to make sure that
the um impacts of that hard surface um
wouldn't adversely affect any of those
existing trees only at a couple of
points would that proposed surface um
sort of venture into the root protection
a of those trees and you'll see that
there's a condition that the council's
Aral officer is satisfied with that
seeks to control the working methods for
the laying of that surface um in those
particular
areas so the proposed extension of the
clubhouse would enhance the available
facilities for the existing lease holder
of the site which is Rochford Town
sports and social club the extension and
hard surfacing around the building would
encroach onto the playing field um and
because of that um allocation of the
site as um open space there is
requirement for consultation with sport
England but they raise no objection the
the actual Sports pitches are further
away so this proposal doesn't um impact
on that directly in any way um the
recommendation is therefore one of
approval subject to the conditions as
set out in the report but you will
notice that there are some additional
amendments to those conditions in the
addendum as
well thank you K uh Ward members uh
councilor
Shaw thank you chairman thank you k for
this um this is so needed and I
certainly would recommend it I was
um I've spoken to people who use this it
is small it is needed to be extended for
the amount of people that do use it
there is adequate car parking by the of
Steel Wells so there's not a problem if
we put more uh people in there there's
plenty of car parking space that um I
have been down there and asked um when
it's the football not to use the side
roads and they've been very good and
they've come back in um and it's always
full but it's overflowing and that's why
I think residents have a problem with
the noise because they cannot be in the
clubhouse there's not enough room the as
Katie said with the um Sports Fields if
they extend it it will not stop the
football going ahead there's a plenty
enough room to the side of it so I
certainly would recommend this for
approval thank
you thank you Council
Ward thank chairman it's just a
clarification on the plans can I just
understand where the serving hatch is
going to be is it going to be on the
neighbor side or on the other side and
the front entrance because if the
serving hatch is going to be towards 28
and 30 would that not be a disturbance
if people are being served from that
side just just need to stand because you
said on that rear side there serving
hatches
k sorry yeah you might want to zoom in
it's quite difficult to see but
essentially it's on that rear elevation
okay so it is on the rear elevation that
does um it is opposite that boundary of
the site with those Residential
Properties it's single story there are
boundary treatments there um
you know we don't anticipate that that
is going to cause nuisance um there are
there is there are conditions as stated
which control the hours of operation um
so we're satisfied that we think the
amenity of those existing nearby
Residential Properties would be
appropriately
protected may I come back yesc all I was
considering is is the simple fact that
if there's a serving hatch the serving
hatch is designed from behind the bar
which I guess is the bar area to serve
people outside who are going to be
congregating in that area not going to
be around the front they're going to be
around the back right by the neighbors I
think that that's probably a touch too
far I'm very happy with this I'm very
happy with what's going on I'm not happy
with the fact that you're going to end
up no matter all the best will in the
world everybody is going to be behind
smoking laughing joking drinking their
beer outside right on top of those
houses and I feel that that's
inappropriate and I I wouldn't be happy
with the serving hatch being there
that's
all coun Stanley thank you chairman um
yes a couple of things there uh the
windows that actually uh look out over
to the neighbors um will they be all
obscure Windows uh and again that
serving act which has just been brought
uh by Council
um the as the property in at the moment
doesn't have adequate parking to put a
bigger property on and have more people
there would it still have an adequate
parking for that and the other thing is
that 9:00 in the morning to 11 o'cl at
night doesn't give much and seven days a
week might I say doesn't give much rest
by to the neighbors
um I would like that restricted
somewhat uh at least during the week um
we have the similar sort of problem with
football in as much as people want to
park everywhere and and the noise is
horrendous it's getting to a situation
where there is no peace for the
neighbors and I'd like to see that
restricted somewhat to to a better times
uh during the week maybe 10 o'clock
and at weekends 11:00 if that's okay can
can I just ask have have there been any
objections from the neighbors to this
application I think
two if you like come back on that yes
please yes okay um so in relation to the
the use um you'll see on the addendum
that's the planning history of the site
is is referred to um and it's it's
there's nothing recent um
really um and but there are conditions
on the 1987 consent which allowed the
bar to be included within the floor
space and that's that existing bar it's
quite small um that you'll see it's not
on the existing floor plan because I
haven't got that on screen but there's
an existing bar allowed under the 1987
consent and that was subject to a
condition that the bar use only be um
allowed to operate between the hours of
9 and 11: p.m. okay um um now that
condition was quite specific it only
related to the bar use so it essentially
people could still be in the building so
what this actual um application does is
it increases the floor area quite
substantially so what we've recommended
is a condition that is 9 to 11 but that
is not just the bar the whole use so
that mosa 11 and that 9 to 11 is
consistent with the premises license
that currently operates has operated at
the site for for many years there has I
spoken to the licensing officer there's
been no review of that license because
there's been no need to because there's
been no um noise um I think like a
certain number of noise complaints might
um instigate a formal review of that
license and there hasn't been anything
like that so according to the licensing
team they're satisfied that that 9 to 11
Works sufficiently in this location to
you know control the use in respect of
the nearby Residential Properties so
actually imposing the planning condition
would seek to mean that people could
only be using that extended building
between 9 and 11 it's consistent with
the license and we don't think it would
be fair to impose a narrower time frame
given that the existing building orbe it
a smaller footprint can actually
operate although they're not allowed to
sell alcohol or or play music after
11:00 p.m. as it currently
stands thank you hang on uh Council
cross first I believe uh thank you chair
yes I have to agree with um Council Ward
the inclusion of a serving hatch on the
North side um implies and encourages um
obviously serving of of customers
outside that particular location so it's
it's encouraging Maybe a new use use
used area for congregating and uh and
having drinks and yeah the noise that
accompanies that also the the fire exit
um in the new part of the building I I
would like to see a condition imposed
there that that that door is kept closed
during the summer months um and you know
I can imagine that when it's hot they'll
want that door open and there's going to
be music and loud uh conversation and
Etc in in that part of the building so
although there there's been no noise
objections thus far they haven't had two
major entrances and exits uh on that
north side of of the building so there
may well be objection we we're just you
know I think there'll be objections
going forward if that serving hatch and
you know encouraging people outside to
congregate at that serving hatch so can
we impose a condition where the the exit
doors are kept closed um and the serving
hatches is well not put
in can I suggest that we've we've got
quite a few speakers uh on Katie if you
can make a note of that the questions
that are coming and then if I can come
back to you after everyone's had to say
yeah okay thanks uh Council
conable I was uh going to propose um
that the condition of planning consent
would be the removal of that serving
hatch and um a condition that no um
alcohol is taken to the rear of the
property
as I think there's a bit of a cross over
there to licensing um I'm not sure
that's a a
planning issue I'm not sure take advice
on that but um yeah
um counc
wlson thank you chair it has been
suggested said to me that maybe we could
um ask for a condition to go on to limit
the hours that the um serving hatch is
open for and I don't know if it's
possible but maybe we could do that with
the um fire X or the the doors at the
rear as well thank
you
ccy thank you
chairman um I've got no problem with
this as it stands I've sitting now the
serving hatch is probably there cuz I
found a useful there doesn't seem to be
very much room for people to stand to
sit down or have picnics around there to
make loads of noise it just sorts like
they get drinks or something on a
Saturday morning and wander off
somewhere else I can't really see a
problem with it and if there is a
problem it' be done under licensing some
will make a noise complaint and it would
be investigated by a licensing Authority
same as a lot of the other problems
there what we seem to be suggesting
aren't really problems to be dealt with
us they dealt with by the police with
noise and other and pieces which is all
in the
report I'm quite happy to support this
so I don't want us lame and put in in
conditions which okay we might we might
assume but assuming is not the best
sometimes the best thing to do we should
leave it to our
staty officers to deal with these other
things later if there are
complaints okay thank you uh councel
Shaw just one point um this application
they feel that they do need a serving
hatch there is obviously problems where
other members think it shouldn't be at
the back perhaps we could inste a sign
having a condition that says remove it
could it be could we have ask them if it
could be
recited that's that's just a thought
thank you very
much I might I might just come back on a
few I know there's more but if you can
is that okay so I think um in relation
to the serving hatch thanks CLA but they
put the um the if you zoom in even a
little bit more on that proposed Flor
plan please because the serving hatch is
directly related to the kitchen so I
think it's going to be problematic to
try to to move that and my my
inclination is that the way this would
operate although you know I know this is
not necessarily going to be the case
always but it would allow you know the
serving of food to like um you know
breakfast bun or whatever it is when
you're rocking up to the site early
morning or something on the roof when
maybe the whole building is not open
because why would you use a serving
hatch when you've got access to the
actual seating area to allow people in
so it would seem that this is just to
enable that use um maybe when the whole
building isn't open um and you know I
think we're satisfied that that that
would wouldn't be
unreasonable um
in this scenario I think what we also
have to be mindful of in terms of
imposing conditions about in relation to
the doors is there are existing doors in
the building so yes the floor area is
increasing and allowing more people in
there but there is um the condition that
says it's limited to 11: p.m and the
license for selling although that's only
limited to alcohol would relate would
would maybe um be have to be reviewed um
in the case of of noise complaints in
the opening of those fire doors um I
think there was mention of um conditions
limiting the sale of that alcohol being
brought round to the rear of the
property and I just don't think that's
enforcable because you know you know
planning officers aren't going to be
able to enforce that you know every day
or every evening or when whenever that
happens we can't control people's kind
of movements around that building that's
for different authorities if that causes
a problem um
and I think
the I think there was mention of um this
might been a little bit previously but I
think I've cobbled together some notes
of All questions to come back to
adequate parking you know is set out in
the report we are satisfied that there
there would be adequate parking in the
car park that the counselor has um
referred to which is just off to the
east of Steel Wells it's quite a large
car park so we don't think there'd be
any concern there so I think in terms of
these openings in the rear elev
um I think officers are minded to say
that this relationship doesn't seem to
cause any problem at present and there
is already a kitchen some of these this
window there are windows existing and I
would think that they may be openable
windows I can't give you that guarantee
here but there are existing windows in
that rear elevation they're probably
opening um and I think that kitchen
that's
proposed be reasonable to give them an
opening window they proposed to use it
as a serving hatch but if they hadn't
labeled it as serving hatch and just an
openable window it could operate in the
same way allow people to pass food out
to a
customer counselor Wilson first thanks
chairman um Katie sort of stolen my
thunder a bit but uh that if you look at
the relationship where the bar area is
um it's quite away from the serving
hatch so I don't think that that's going
to be a problem I think it's
it's likely to be used in the way that
Katie suggests because it's coming off
the
kitchen thank you councelor
ward I concur with that uh assessment
from councelor Wilson having now looked
at it there's a big separation you've
got the fire exit if you can bring it up
please close as you
can you can you can see again where the
kitchen is it is separated uh I mean the
only condition that that you would say
maybe suggest that uh serving hatch used
between certain hours which doesn't
impede the use of the nine till uh 2300
but let's say you use the serving hatch
just for serving food it shuts off at a
certain time and that may be something
so it wouldn't really interfere with any
of the
neighbors thank you Council Ward um I I
do think that um we we're encroaching on
other areas here with
licensing um that's my my personal
feeling um and so I think it could be
dealt under licensing and I think we do
have to uh give sufficient weight to the
ward counselor's
um explanation that this is very much
needed um so unless anyone else has got
anything to say I think we should go to
the vote um so I need a
proposer councelor shorta that makes
sense and the second Council award thank
you those in favor please
indicate
okay thank you members that is unanimous
and with
that
at uh 16 minutes past N I declare this
meeting closed thank you very much for
all your contributions
tonight